wir probieren es mit den kopf ein
bisschen zu strecken franz okay es war
aber wir haben irgendwie eine minute
oder seine stimme ac 130 sind
mittlerweile aber es natürlich trotzdem
nicht so super viel ich probiere ihr mir
den kids to be zu wecken
auf den ersten seiten ich bin dran habe
ihn auch perfekt ist zwar noch ganze 15
sekunden hilfe rinde die post geht ab
ihr soll kuranyi und wir spielen heute
auf dem team oder server einen team tony
und zwar der werte herr - tut und ich
weiß wie es geht
und es sind 30 teams mittlerweile drin
waren es ist wirklich krass ich hab
jetzt www tecan zusammen einen immer
okay den recht mehr alles klar wir
können uns gegeneinander aus schlagen
also aufbrechen völlig und begeben uns
ich habe den einen dann der andere gibt
ihren krieg sowie team entwickelt habe
die haben allerdings noch eine chance
jetzt sich zu revanchieren ich weiß gar
nicht viele wie lang geht denn der spaß
wird wahrscheinlich hatte ich einfach
zwischen den runden und mache mache nur
die kämpferin weil ich denke man muss
wirklich eine ganze eine ganze weile
warten ja seine pfeile sind plötzlich
nebel ist ein bisschen schlecht gefallen
gerade aber es kann ich meine fall noch
mal ganz gut einsetzen wahrscheinlich
beiden apps aber auch blöd ein bisschen
mehr klar ist hat die mega offene
standards musste aber ich habe es eine
ganze
fakt ist viele noch übrig aber ich
treffe einfach im blut
das ist natürlich stark egal heute 25
sekunden ich weiß nicht ob noch drei
herzen der wahrscheinlich mehr kann man
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch irgendwie so
ein anti ghosting dingen oder du meinst
jetzt medien herzlich angezeigt ein 0 5
hatte er
was jetzt noch mal noch mal der kampf ja
noch mal gegen die unbarmherzig gewinnen
sind wir aus hude ok wo das quali phase
ich kann das nur eine runde gewinnen
die phase habe ich zwei runden
eingestellt also etwas unentschieden die
entscheidungsrunde dass wir gehen wir
jetzt zu zweit auf ein okay das auf es
zweimal getroffen wir haben auch noch
was drauf nochmal nochmal nochmal der
s-bahn wird wahrscheinlich gesagt jetzt
erst kommt der andere alter irgendwie
ergibt der richter ist irgendwas stimmt
da nicht bei mir also es ist längst ein
bisschen rum
er ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen etwa
keine ahnung ja ich hoffe man kann es
sehen und denken ich bin dumm anstellt
die gastierte würde ja was auch immer
hast du getötet
wir sind schon weiter respekt herr kann
langsamer sein erzählen dann sehen wir
uns gleich noch mal zu sehen wie der
zweiten runde ich hatte eigentlich gar
nicht karten müssen aber jetzt nichts
geredet die ganze zeit und ich habe nie
wie die nicht verrückt und direkt auf
lasst uns auf lee die mcg im ziel gehen
hier direkt alles klar platte ist es der
appell ist erobert den kleinkaliber
scherz von den etwas auf ersten fall
sehr gut sieht es auch gegenseitig an
meinte stoner
ja genau aber halt dafür ob wir andere
möglichkeiten angezündet aber bin down 1
klatsche ich ihn nach hause
da ich bin auch bin noch nicht so
wirklich eingespielt müsste wissen leute
weil ich erst so schön ganze ganze weile
nicht mehr gezeigt habe ja nicht
aber wir machen das trotzdem meine
freunde des 2 zweiter sieg hoffentlich
wir gehen wieder zuerst auf diesem level
und konnte wie auch boost alter schwer
gemacht wie so gut dämmen schulterblatt
hat übrigens ein leckerli aus versehen
genutzt die konnten lag mit nutzen doch
noch aus versehen in dem mann steckt
etwas überlegt perfekt meist idee teams
nur noch dann wird es in der nächsten
runde wieder so dass wir auch wieder bei
der nächsten runde wie ich dachte ich
hätte es geschafft und nun legt ja dass
wenn man über motiviert ist aber ich
habe mit wasser gemacht
alex du natürlich mit bastian sonst ja
spinnen weben
das wäre kompletter schwachsinn er will
darauf haben die fakten den kriegen wir
den krieg ja ich glaube wir schlagen uns
ganz gut muss ich sagen
also ich habe den bus shuttle sind wir
natürlich ein bisschen bisschen besser
als die anderen behaupten weil wir uns
einfach absprechen können
wer weiß ja gar nicht also wir schätzen
uns sogar schon durch noch sechs
verbleibenden teams was sind wir auch
wieder bei der nächsten runde ist jetzt
noch sechs teams trennen oder vier teams
verbleiben kraft eines danach schon das
finale im halbfinale
die machen ja auch schon auf taktik die
kollegen heute ohnehin anders unten
dehnt den denen wir zu zweit ok ok
werden nur einer
ich nehme den plan scans da nehme ich
bin schon auf dreieinhalb herzen ja ich
glaube den eigentlich hatten halt
schnappe mir sehr gut
hartmann ich will ihn nicht holy aber
ich schaff millionen oder doch die liebe
noch beide halte auf den ersten und
nicht als gesehen warnt jetzt will ich
hoffentlich eine größere hilfe barcelona
und bayern spielen auch halbfinale oder
auch der name ist in die luft wasser und
bayern sind gar nicht so gut wir kommen
ins halbfinale
zumal das wären so gut dann ist es eine
entschuldigung dass sie vor dem
gestanden ich find sie ein bisschen zu
wenig feilen catrin ist ja eigentlich
auch du kannst aber dafür die fahrer
aufhören ja das ist ja auch schon was
wert musste guter alter freund sich
nicht beschweren hier alles gut
getroffen
gut wir sind im finale des getränks
keine altlast diesmal nicht mal lässt
sich machen ist weil manchmal
absichtlich läuft also schon von selbst
los aus über motivation und dann ist es
immer sehr knapp kommen wir haben mal
ihre pfeile auf jeden fall ein vorteil
als bezahlte tactics mama soziale
bericht wörtlich geschlagen als schlimm
ich kandidiere ich weiß nicht bremsen
weil sie nicht lassen etwas nach oben
gehen und wasser fallen lassen
magath ich bin auf ihre herzen ich bin
auch relativ laut schon aber ich habe
mir den fokus
ihre ganzen pfeile auf gesamt ja was
information nach 20 sekunden
der mega deal.de die kampfzeit mehr kurz
eingestellt das war wahrscheinlich auch
nicht so
der vorteil ok nein hab den einen hab
den 1
ok de nice hat oder wir uns gegenseitig
nenne ich habe gewonnen
nehmen wir uns gegenseitig getötet der
andere sich für den chef und ich hoffe
ich habe keine eine rückkopplung
ich habe nämlich die ganze dann aber du
hast eine schön gut dann den rechten als
erster ok oder nicht erst an dem erst
dann ergibt ein bisschen egal
das finale und hasst ihn
er hat nicht aber er ist richtig dass
ich hab ihn one shot noch okay kraft eg
richtig gutes teamwork aber ich denke
mal wir hängen noch eine runde dran was
ginge so schnell dass wir einfach noch
mal ganz schnell eine neue runde
erstellen das team noch überarbeiten und
sehen wir uns gleich wieder so dass wir
auch wieder bei der nächsten runde und
ich hoffe wir können wieder so
erfolgreich kämpfen aber niemals diesen
diesen kollegen hier am besten macht man
ja also wir haben genau das volk - sein
wir haben jetzt nicht diese blöcke drin
weil man konnte sich davor so ein
bisschen hoch bauen wusste ich gar nicht
mal okay leute es schon dauern also man
konnte ich dafür hoch waren aber nämlich
noch böcke drin und ich habe vier fall
noch mehr rein also statt vier wie es
davor war jetzt acht weiteren und
probiere mit ich sag mal erst mal wieder
ein paar von denen ja ja aber mit wasser
das der topix rückte desto fix oder so
direkt schon wieder durch getränke sehen
ist gleich wieder
außerdem wir dann auch wieder meine
freunde zur nächsten runde und ich muss
die ganze zeit in den in den kleinen
pausen dazwischen halte ich die ganze
zeit so die hand hoch damit die fleißig
rausschneiden arm so ein bisschen
eingeschlafen mich auf mein kann
trotzdem will man ständig kämpfen
aber ich euch die fabrik hoffen vergeben
egal ob dieses friendly fires damit ist
irgendwie nicht so ganz auf dem schirm
aber hier sehr schön
das hat sogar sein team and getötet
öffentlich er steht da unten mohamed m
brigitte passiert ist ein bisschen 30
fans korans ausschalten kann
ja geht es gar nicht gut soweit ich weiß
nicht so heiß alte wir durchmarschieren
das sind immer so fünf sekunden kam nach
den ganzen quatsch wieder ein video auf
das medium eva penis auf das feld herr
ich da sind wir wieder was mit ihr euch
das deutschland gesagt habe wie rubin
ist mit den köpfen bisschen zu strecken
es war aber wir haben eine minute oder
seine stimme ac 130 sind mittlerweile
aber es natürlich trotzdem nicht so
super vielen problemen wir den dienst
ruby zu wecken
auf den ersten seiten ich bin als sowie
dran haben auch perfekten 111 war noch
ganze 15 sekunden hilfe rinde nächstes
jahr auf jeden fall zum anfang was neues
sagen
irgendwas muss gucken was neues
einfallen lassen
ich weiß gar nicht ist bei wago friendly
fire ag als ist friendly fire watch
friendly fires er was ich also es kommt
so von cod und sonderkräfte dass man
sich gegenseitig abschießen kann
eigentlich muss man fast schon wieder
fast aller länder
jetzt mache ich einfach zur begrüßung
käserei ich war damit rein springen
gleich abgesessen hat dessen was dann
für mich ich mache einfach wenn mir
langweilig ist mache ich einfach immer
die weil ich sagst du
das ist einfach leicht für mich die
haben dann wird's am arsch der gema
ziemlich dick gepolsterten kleckert
leicht brandy aber in einem diesen
heute haben wir gewonnen haben die auf
der treppe auf dem gehsteig ich bin auf
almeria ist das ist genau was wir
wollten wir wollten erst mal eine kleine
challenger die drecks karte mit dem lg
das ein bisschen hinten bleiben ja weißt
du was wir machen können daraus wir
können uns die karte zu eigen machen
wir machen uns jetzt diesen kleinen turm
die uns gar nichts machen weil wir sind
die besten
ein profi kämpfen wenn man auch einfach
stehen können aber wir haben nur eine
minute 30 das stimmt aber wir löschen
denn die mittel und übernimmt das ganze
gehen
ich hab die wollnys aufmachen würde ich
ja normal
die machen aber die sind noch getrennt
wollte wohl aufgeben warnte die unteren
blätter und rollen perfekt getrennte ist
gut das kann keiner ist hier nicht
selten leute dies gab mir ich nicht okay
das war richtig dass natürlich auch
stark
komm mein freund aber ich habe ihn auch
getroffen als ob kunden gefallen dir
bleibt der mitte der will nämlich recht
aber natürlich wäre bestimmt oder der
klick mich sogar noch mehr kriegt mich
nicht ich hab ihn zukommt schade ist
weiter gefallen schade gewesen und auf
die finale runde an meine freunde
okay die kasse das war schon krank war
wieder einmal zu den linken gehen okay
man optimal zu den abonnenten nett sein
kannst kannst du deinen job erfolg ich
bin auf einem herz ich habe den einen
gleich weiter da aber ich hab den ersten
ich komme zu dir gott tollem service
wird direktorin house trance house ihre
hände und zu hause gegen ich kann mich
gar nicht kommt der hat doch eine feile
der entschließe ich habe zweimal
getroffen
herzlicher fiel vor allem eines sein
mein freund ich bin direkt weiter ich
spiele gerade in turm ein freundlicher
kann gerade nicht zu meinen shops märz
ein weilchen konzentrieren musste können
hält weiter geht das ewig brauchen weil
da müssen wir nicht kannten
du musst du nicht kann sagt der lag
jetlag wahlalter der metzger hatte mich
weg beklatschte jetzt koffer packen
schäden auf der welt man stimmt sich auf
jeder mal gewonnen freund stempel sind
weiter ich bin schon ab der herzen mit
zwei torschüssen ich glaub dir geben uns
ja fix ob der eine der hat schon wieder
wasser genommen nämlich kriegt ihr nicht
nein sind wir raus wir dürfen ihn raus
sein sonst auch man nein das geht nicht
erproben
wir sind raus wurden 50 wir wurden
zweiter platz damals gut leute wir sind
wirklich